short summary of what the cdu stands for
the Christian democratic union is a Christian
and also a very old party
it stands for conservative values
a conservative family image for many things
so for preserve and not so much for modernize
that is
traditional values are important to you in principle
it has of course changed in the last 150
years also strongly changed
but it is still a party
which rather relies on
that which works well
To maintain and,
if necessary,
further develop
and the not so much um at modernization uh
interested in the sense is um
even the family picture is still often one of the
which is very conservative
and sometimes it is quite funny to see
how she argues um
various topics while saying reasons
environmental protection because nature animals
this that the cdu says rather
we want to preserve the creation
has so again ne other orientation
i like to work with the cdu
but also notice quite often
we are already partially
really far from each other